the 26 year old was walking with her two
children near eastern and bonanza on
tuesday
when she was hit and killed by a car an
event held today focused on helping the
family members she left behind
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
joins us live near the crash site in the
east valley tonight
with more madison
yes the fundraiser was held for the late
mother of two honoring her life
and also providing funds for the family
left behind
it's hard to me right now because it was
part of my family andrea
and right now we need to
work together with the family to be
supporting these kids emotional support
was all around today for the late andrea
lopez de castillas and her family
the 26 year old mother of two died this
past week
after being hit by a car while crossing
the street an outdoor ceremony was held
here where friends and family gathered
to raise funds for lopez's children
tables were spaced out and there was a
limited number of guests
nevada state assemblyman edgar flores
joined the family
and shared some words two beautiful kids
behind
with a sister morning a mother morning
and
at this time the community came together
because we know how expensive it is and
fortunate to bury a child excuse me
to bury a family member and so everybody
here
is donating either food money they're
doing
different raffles whatever they can to
help this family in need
mindy lloyd wife of late metro
lieutenant eric lloyd knows all too well
what it's like to endure sudden loss
she made a donation in hopes that she
can help with the kids future
we want to be able to help with the
funeral and we want to be able to help
with the future
i mean we're talking about these these
are little babies
you know they they need counseling
they need medical help
and as you can see there's an on-site
memorial with candles
and flowers right off of bonanza road
now if you would like to help
we have a gofundme page set up on our
website
there's a link to that where you can go
and help out the family
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now